at the beginning of last year Morgan
Stanley Equity strategist Michael Wilson
is one of the few to predict stock
market losses he was proven right as the
S P 500 had its worst year since 2008
but it makes sense why we're seeing this
type of price action we do have this
collision between tightening fed and
slowing growth this year he's projecting
that stocks will fall even further I'm
going to explain just how far Wilson
thinks stocks will tumble why he
believes the market won't recover this
year and break down what the numbers
tell us about the current state of U.S
equities let's get into it given that we
are about to enter the last calendar
month of the first quarter later this
week we think the risk of stocks falling
further is high in a note written in
late February Michael Wilson said he
expects the S P 500 default 25 from its
current levels this year that would
knock the Benchmark U.S stock index down
to levels it hasn't touched since the
spring of 2020. this is well below the
norm among Equity analysts at the big
Banks and it's got many calling in the
biggest Barrel bolster so why is is
Wilson so bearish first he argues that
stocks are currently very expensive
given the risks that the market is
facing he points to what's known as the
equity risk premium or the expected
return for stocks versus an investment
in U.S treasury bonds according to
Morgan Stanley's calculations that's at
the lowest level since 2007. second
Wilson says that even though stock
earnings are expected to decline
analysts are being far too generous with
their projections he thinks that
companies are going to underperform and
that will push stock prices down even
further and third wall Street's biggest
bear agrees with many other strategists
who say the Federal Reserve is far from
done raising U.S interest rates and
tightening Financial conditions if rates
go higher than investors are expecting
that will put even more pressure on
companies and consumers the data
certainly suggests there are reasons to
be worried about stock prices earnings
for companies in the S P 500 are
expected to fall by nearly five percent
in the latest quarter that would be the
worst since the third quarter of 2020
and companies net profit margins or the
percentage of every dollar of sales they
make is profit is expected to fall for
the sixth straight quarter the fed's
latest survey of loan officers also
shows Banks keep raising their standards
and fewer companies are coming to them
for loans there's also the fact that
investors can earn close to 5 percent by
keeping their money in one year U.S
treasury bonds which are considered
risk-free since the U.S government has
never defaulted to be sure many top
money managers like the equity
strategist at JP Morgan believe stock
prices will rebound from 2022's Big
losses because the FED will reverse
course and start lowering interest rates
later this year they believe that will
drive money back into the market and
push stock prices higher but Wilson and
other strategists at places like
Barclays Deutsche Bank and Jeffries so
the FED holding rates high in order to
battle inflation even in the face of a
painful recession only time will tell
who has it right when markets are
uncertain it's always wise to keep
putting money away like rappers smoke
dizza says he notes every 200 I make I
gotta tuck 40. having me 2m saved by the
time I touch 40.
that's all for now see you next time